le match france belgique c'est donc dans
quelques heures mais d'ici là vous avez
largement le temps de regarder point de
vue merci beaucoup d'être avec nous je
voudrais d'abord qu'on regarde des
images de cet heureux évènement du jour
les enfants dans la grotte en thaïlande
ont tous été sortis sains et saufs les
derniers sont sortis il ya quelques
heures on voit les images c'est celle
des sauveteurs là qui progresse sous
terre il était donc que 12 leur
entraîneur à être retenu sous terre
depuis quinze jours ils sont maintenant
tous à l'air libre
un heureux dénouement la fifa les avait
même invité à aller assister à la finale
du mondial
ils ne pourront pas le faire ils sont
encore trop fragile disent les autorités
ils ont d'ailleurs du mal à se ré
acclimater à la lumière la fin donc
heureuse de ce long suspense bonjour
alexandre malafaye merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous présidez le think tank si
nokia et vous avez publié
c'était en août 2014 reprenons pouvoir
manifeste pour notre droit à être bien
gouverner on va parler comme ça vaste
programme
bonjour nicolas core atom beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
vous êtes spécialiste de la
communication vous dirige à la fois
place de la république
institut de recherche politique pour
ranimer le débat public et la fabrique
de l'opinion est une agence de
communication destinée aux entreprises
et aux institutions bonjour benoît
dumoulin merci nous avoir rejoints vous
êtes rédacteur en chef adjoint de
l'incorrect magazine qui se décrit comme
le mensuel de toutes les droites et vous
avez co écrit avec charles beigbeder
charnellement de france paru en 2007 aux
éditions pierre guillaume de route
bonjour marc landré bonjour dans les
lecteurs en chef adjoint du service et
quads commence à moins j'ai été
rétrogradée rédacteur en chef et en plus
vous avez la dernière vous avez
maillot alors là vous avez fait un bel
effort ouais ouais je sais pas si ces
points de vue qui vont voter pas ce
point là parce qu'on sait en tout cas
les internautes qui vous suivent savent
que c'est plutôt le tennis que le foot
qui en portent vos suffrages tout à fait
mais là on salue votre patriotisme et
bien écoutez on va parler de tout ça
mais d'abord cette ce congrès à
versailles alors à la tribune hier
emmanuel macron annoncé que l'an
prochain ils descendraient dans l'air
dans l'arène pour répondre aux questions
des parlementaires
du coup une partie de l'opposition lui
reproche de désacraliser la fonction
présidentielle
jupiter alors je voudrais tout faire et
il trahirait l'esprit de la vème
république cette critique est elle
justifiée
on en parle dans un instant mais d'abord
on écoute bruno retailleau bruno
retailleau sénateur de vendée président
des républicains au sénat il était ce
matin sur europe 1 le premier ministre
lui est responsable devant le parlement
devant les parlementaires c'est au
premier ministre d'assumer cette
fonction
le président de république et lui
responsable devant le peuple ce que
proposait modèles ba kron c'est une
sortie de régime
une sortie de la cinquième république il
ne se contente plus d'être un président
monarque
il veut cumuler et être un président
premier ministre président la république
et premiers ministres à la fois oui
c'est en tout cas c'est le sentiment que
ça donne même si le président est bon
brillant talentueux tout ce qu'on veut
hier c'est vraiment de l'exercice de
politique générale au lycée dirait bien
davantage qu'un exercice présidentielle
en plaçant les enjeux de sa fonction et
sa mission au bon niveau
après il ya des choses qui sont
préoccupantes le côté gadget qui
consiste dans l'an prochain je reviens
et puis je répondre aux questions enfin
faire un débat un contre 900 parts de
fonds mais c'est pas sérieux quoi dire
ça ça va répondre à quelques questions
ça fera quelques phrases mais c'est pas
le sujet et puis après ce qui est quand
même préoccupant c'est cette can cette
fâcheuse dérives du jeu hier qu' il est
vraiment au centre qui se met au centre
et ce qui moi m'inquiète c'est qu'en
fait il est hier il a fait quelque chose
qui revient il a planifié les chèques ni
je ne réussirais pas tout mais la parade
à l'échec du jeu c'est le nous c'est de
dire tout d'un coup on puisque jeu tout
seul je peux pas tout faire je me fais
en sorte que voilà ce soit pas je sais
nous c'est un collectif
et hier cette idée de notion de
collectif on l'a pas bien perçu ça pour
moi en termes de gouvernance on en a un
vrai sujet présidentialisation et
personnalisation à l'excès et puis et
puis si vous voulez il faut pas se
tromper on voit bien que encore une
forme de jeunesse puisque il ya un
mélange des non seulement des gens dans
la fonction depuis des mots dire gérer
c'est une chose hier on a plutôt vu un
discours de quelqu'un qui gère avec sur
des sujets sur les dossiers qui nous
donne une vision par rapport à ça mais
y'a pas la [ __ ] pictures
c'est pas le mot gouverner et c'est
encore moins le mot décider qui soit son
niveau pour dire amener je décide parce
que je suis président ça me paraît
cohérent mais le reste est du collectif
et donc effectivement il faut bien ce
pas se tromper de répartition des rôles
et hier on a vraiment le sentiment
l'énergie de fusion préoccupante mecalac
au râteau il a joué sur tous les
registres et manière là je crois qu'il
faut pas non plus exagérer on parle
beaucoup d'un discours de politique
générale pour ce qui est passé hier
c'est surtout un très long discours qui
a duré une heure et demie je crois que
beaucoup de parlementaires s'en sont
plaints était un peu mais on n'est plus
surpris avec le président macron général
et une emphase et un problème de
calendrier sur ses discours comme un peu
un peu problématique c'est intéressant
d'entendre bruno retailleau se plaint de
l'hyper présidentialisation du régime
enfin on rappelle que l'examen auquel
s'est livrée et emmanuel macron au
congrès que de critiques bruno
retailleau c'est quand même nicolas
sarkozy qu'il a institutionnalisé cette
capacité est autorisé cette capacité du
président allait s'exprimer devant le
congrès et d'autre part il expliqué
bruno retailleau que
emmanuel macron préparer la sortie de
régime on a l'impression que macron et
dans le même combat que jean luc
mélenchon n'en n'est quand même pas là
moi c'est pas tant un discours de
politique générale que j'ai entendu hier
c'est un peu un discours sur l'état de
l'union
c'est plus à ça que ça m'a fait penser
et quand on parle de la présent 17
présidentialisation je pense que la
référence de macron n'est pas française
elle est américaine et qu'effectivement
si on est sur une évolution du régime je
pense que la pensée de macron c'est
d'aller vers une présidence de style
américaine aux etats-unis le président
s'en va après avoir prononcé son
discours et personne me répond donc
contradictoire avec les mais il est en
même temps aux états unis et en même
temps en france et elle il faut aussi
pouvoir cumuler les deux besoin
benoît du moulin à les français
apprécient cette forme d'autorité alors
oui les français apprécient le côté
verticale du pouvoir qui avait été
perdue sous l'ancienne présidence
et c'est vrai que là on a retrouvé un
côté un côté un peu monarque républicain
qui correspond aux esprits à l'esprit de
la constitution de la vème république
en revanche l'hyper prénom si l'hyper
prédisent près je vais avait
présidentialisation qui effectivement ne
date pas des manuels macron meeddat
vraiment de nicolas sarkozy qui était à
la fois présidents deux premiers
ministres et donc c'est pour ça que
bruno retailleau aujourd'hui a beau jeu
de critiquer ce qui l'a approuvé
précédemment
cette hyper président
présidentialisation et
à mon sens très dangereuses pour
l'esprit des institutions
pourquoi parce que ça revient finalement
à faire du premier ministre en
l'occurrence edouard philippe
un exécutant on l'entend uniquement
quand il s'agit de limiter la vitesse à
80 donc c'est très bien mais bon sang on
dirait un espèce de super préfet qui
vous suivent quand vous allez un peu
trop vite sur la route mais en revanche
le président est partout il omniprésent
et pourquoi c'est grave parce que
justement là dans la sagesse des du
législateur constitué en 1958 le premier
set un fusible et au bout de deux ans
trois ans il ya une des mécontentements
une grave crise sociale
on peut le remplacer et ont fait sauter
le fusible le président lui est vraiment
centré sur les affaires étrangères la
défense et là on se rend compte que le
président encaisse tout mais il
il encaisse l'impopularité baisse de 10
points dans les sondages et le problème
c'est que c'est lui la clé de voûte des
institutions
donc c'est on est un peu dans une
impasse avec celle de marc landré ça me
rappelle ce qui s'est passé il ya dix
ans on avait exactement les mêmes
critiques à l'encontre dit nicolas
sarkozy qui prenaient tous les coups
qu'ils s'exposaient trop qui avait un
premier ministre collaborateurs vêtue
d'une foi qui lui ne prenez pas de
risque était plus haut que lui dans les
sondages et que donc ils ne savaient pas
du rôle de fusible que doit avoir elle
doit être un prêt ministre en cas de
débâcle qu'il débat
oui alors là je pense qu on est en l2 en
france de se faire des deux sphères des
tempêtes dans des verres d'eau dans
l'est dans les cerveaux bien avertit
emmanuel macron utilise une possibilité
qui lui est offerte par la constitution
jusqu'à preuve du contraire la
constitution n'est pas un déni de
démocratie
bien au contraire après il le fait avec
son style avec son talent et ses défauts
effectivement des discours trop longs
son talent c'est qu'il est quand même
capable d'avoir une pensée construite et
plus construite que certains de ses
prédécesseurs à commencer par françois
hollande
après juste deux choses la capacité
qu'il aura peut-être l'année prochaine
de s'expliquer c'est simplement sa
volonté de toujours avoir le dernier mot
il veut pas qu'on parle après lui donc
il veut pouvoir s'exprimer sauf que qui
a regardé hier le débat qui a succédé le
spi du présent à public moi il y avait
personne dans l'hémicycle bah oui oui ça
va faire venir il y avait personne dans
l'hémicycle donc c'est à dire que les
députés les sénateurs avaient filiale
anglaise pour aller voir un match n'y a
pas de match mais pour faire autre chose
en tout cas c'était quoi c'était des
séquences de ce pitch de monologues de
gens qui montent à la tribune auquel
personne ne répondait là y'avait pas de
débat donc le fait qu en vérité ce que
ce que se donne emmanuel macron c'est la
possibilité de parler en dernier ressort
l'année prochaine après tout les
monologues dont on savait déjà avant qui
parlent ce qu'ils allaient dire deuxième
chose vous savez que hier il ya un
amendement qui a été déposée par le vice
président des républicains qui s'appelle
damien abad au projet de loi sur la
constitution qui autorise et le
président de la république a retourné
l'année prochaine devant le congrès
après avoir parlé pour s'expliquer et
bien cet amendement républicain a été
retiré parce qu'il ne correspondait pas
à la ligne du parti
ça veut dire que même dans le
contentieux il ya des gens qui
considèrent que c'est peu c'est
peut-être pas inutile que le président
reste pour expliquer à quoi sert aussi
dans marche il y avait aussi un
amendement en ce sens mais on alors dire
que ça c'est des présidents précédents
l'annnonce de
chers sont très souvent des gens qui
obéissent uniquement en consignant et de
l'oxydé ça fait discipline oued
alexandra vous écriviez dans l'opinion
je crois que c'était hier notre confrère
l'opinion la confiance en soi le journal
d'aujourd'hui
vous avez écrit hier c'est paru
aujourd'hui la confiance en soi ne
suffit pas monsieur le président c'est
celle d'un pays tout entier qu'il faut
réveiller les français doivent avoir le
sentiment que votre bonne étoile peut se
transformer en soleil pour tous en fait
moi je suis inquiet parce que si vous
voulez je trouve que là on a la chance
d'avoir un président qui est un talent
quand même assez exceptionnel
il faut le dire je rejoins ce qui a été
dit aux gens qu'il a sans doute les
qualités que certains de ses
prédécesseurs n'avait pas mais mais
quand même son rôle aujourd'hui c'est de
nous alerter
avant de commencer à voir le retour du
soleil ce que j'explique c'est
qu'effectivement en un ensemble de
périls qui sont devant nous deux défis
qui sont devant nous qui sont pas posées
je trouve que notre pays comme nos
opinions sont pas prêts à affronter ce
qui est en train de se passer au 21ème
siècle
et là je pense que s'il voulait le
discours d'hier pourrait pas acheter
votre un discours catalogue avec version
de formule 1 je les ai noté un état
providence émancipateur très bien je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire
à un moment donné d'accord enfin un
moment donné en une minute il nous a
parlé d'islam de laïcité de culture et
de la défense des auteurs en une ligne
les chronomètres et et je peux vous en
citer comme ça plein c'est donc avec
beaucoup de formules beaucoup de mots
sur lesquels on peut se poser plein de
questions y compris des annonces mais
dans laquelle il n'y a rien derrière moi
mon problème de hyères c'est que je dis
est ce que ce président là avec le
talent qui est le sien avec cette
capacité en tout cas à fédérer une
équipe qui est au boulot folha le bus
comme elles sont aurait pas dû hier nous
a contribué à nous préparer dit
attention il fait tout ça parce qu'il ya
un ton de défi parce qu'ils sont
dangereux
mon rôle est un rôle voilà deux voilà
d'entraîneur d'alert bon m après
derrière dire j'ai une équipe on a un
boulot
chacun continuera à le faire mais pas
tout mélanger hier je vois mon sentiment
c'est un sentiment une confusion
il ya trop de messages et je sais pas ce
que les français qui ont regardé ou ceux
qui ont près après leurs émissions
habituelles longeau beatles ce qu'ils en
ont retenu
or un amoureux né en bon communicant il
faut pas tout faire quoi quel effet ça
ne me dire il prépare les matches de
foot
ils ont pardonné le président des
questions c'est parce que ça après les
rencontres pense que rien nous on adore
quand on en parle décrit les journaux
comment
les journalistes comment mais j'ai
l'impression dans l'imagerie populaire
et dans l'opinion publique
ça n'a rien d'un primé et d'ailleurs
c'est le problème actuel d' emmanuel
macron qui connaît la même situation que
ses prédécesseurs
quel que soit son talent au même moment
c'est-à-dire un an après la prise de sa
fonction ou plus rien d'un prime il ya
que vous avez vous présenté des schémas
vous avez beau imaginer une protection
sociale la sécurité sociale du 21e
siècle c'est un crémerie sur la
dépendance qui sont des vrais sujets de
société qu'on essaye en vain de traiter
d'anti l'elysée annonçait bien sûr mais
mais il en reparle concrètement hier sa
n'impriment absolument pas recherche
dans les sondages le prédisent et
durable ah mais je le prédis durable
tout comme pour ses prédécesseurs
reparlons de françois hollande à la même
époque de nicolas sarkozy il ya un
moment j'ai envie de dire et je suis un
peu plus les critiques que vous
alexandre au bout d'un an quinquennat
est terminée et c'était aussi
l'inquiétude emmanuel macron qui
n'arrêtait pas de dire je n'arrêterai
aucune des réformes aucun train des
réformes parce que je sais que j'ai un
nom finalement pour véritablement
impacté le pays après c'est terminé
c'est fini on voit bien qu'il ya une
ganache schéma dans le quinquennat qui
tend à se renouveler et ben oui au bout
d'un an maintenant utile pour le pays ce
qu'on appelle l'état de grâce voilà mais
c'est un peu différent même c'est un
état d'actions et puis ensuite on
revient dans un schéma beaucoup plus le
moutonnier star quelques succès quand
même on les a abondamment commenté ces
derniers mois le bilan d un an il n'est
pas non plus totalement vide
non il n'est pas vide mais justement
c'est bien son problème c'est qu'il sait
que ça va être très compliqué de
remettre la table pour l'année qui vient
et que ça va plus du tout la même
histoire
donc tout ce qui n'a pas passé cette
première année de mandat il sait que ce
sera beaucoup plus compliqué de le
passer par l'avenir et donc je pense
aussi que la confusion parfois
l'arrogance qui ressort ça vient aussi
peut-être d'un état de nervosité par
rapport au fait qu' on sent les choses
qui vous échappe un peu naturellement au
bout d'un an de mandat j'ai l'impression
que c'est le schéma naturel on vous pose
la question sur twitter emmanuel macron
at il pris la place du premier ministre
hier au congrès à versailles vous êtes
déjà majorité 55% à dire que oui
emmanuel macron à le tendance à se
prendre un peu pour edouard philippe
alors edouard philippe on en parle deux
secondes je voulais bien c'est vrai vous
l'avez évoqué benoît du moulin alors
super préfet 80 km il est un commentaire
tiens marc landré sur le edouard
philippe aujourd'hui il était on a tous
dit il évaluer les ministres les uns
après les autres elles à s'évaluer et
doit s'auto évaluer
oui puisqu'il est très bon premier
ministre il a envie dans le rôle que le
président lui a confiée et il en sort
qui sort pas du cadre alors oui il a
sorti un petit peu sur les 80 km heure
il souhaite taper sur la tête pour ça
c'est la seule initiative qu'il a pris
ce qui est contesté à l'intérieur même
du gouvernement
vous prenez le rêve des décisions qui
sont directement impulsée par le
président il n'y a pas de débat
là ils sont les marcheurs ils marchent
ils droit ils sont ils en voient pas une
tête qui dépasse derrière le présent à
un public y joue son rôle il joue sa
carte
personne ne le connaissait il ya un an
aujourd'hui il a une petite popularité
il est plus populaire que le président
légèrement voilà il continuer et en plus
je veux dire je pense que il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas véritablement de différence de
fond entre les deux et moi ce qui
m'amuse beaucoup c'est qu'encore cet
après midi c'est dans le pré ministre
critiqué l'opposition alors qu'il ya
encore un an il était il était assis sur
le même banc que et qui prônait disais
exactement la même chose
voilà c'est cocasse et puis sur
l'évaluation de pardon enfin c'est un
outil de travail qu'on utilise dans les
entreprises on n'a pas affaire aux mêmes
types de population ça ce sont les
ministres des secrets d'état alors
qu'après il ya des réunions de travail
pour faire un point à date sur les
fameuses feuilles de route qui avait été
là et de voir où on en est et de d'aidé
chacun des ministres en fonction des
sujets des situations peut être comment
on peut améliorer par tel type dha
proches par une meilleure communication
pas refuser interministériel par je ne
sais pas en tout cas voilà va nous
présenter cela comme des entretiens
d'évaluation que m'ont fait des
collaborateurs dans une entreprise voilà
on a un peu l'impression qu'on mélange
les fins la fin et les moyens quoi oui
mais bon c'est comme c'est comme le fait
de revenir la nième l'an prochain pour
dit on va faire un débat 900 c'est de la
com ce sont des gadgets et je pense que
là aussi les français moment donné ils
comprennent que bon
résultat tout à qu'emmanuel macron à ce
sont essentiellement des résultats qui
sont liées à la politique et venise en
oeuvre françois hollande la politique de
l'offre camille françois hollande en
oeuvre points et les fruits des
politiques et des réformes de emmanuel
macron on ne les voit pas encore oui ce
qu'il a changé c'est l'image de la
france dans le monde c'est vrai qu'il a
redonné une verticalité la fonction
présidentielle il a changé l'image du
président et de la france dans le monde
tout le monde aujourd'hui nous envient
un président jeune dynamique qui
séduisant alors qu'avant on nous
reprochait un président un gars est
vieux et une certaine confiance dans les
milieux économiques insuffisantes de
l'investissement briller quand il n'est
pas non plus tôt n'ait déjà revenue au
site en france à l'horizon il ya une
accélération avec emmanuel macron parce
qu'il vient de chez eux
pire ils sont ils sont ils ont été
biberonné dans les mêmes écoles et dans
les dents les dans les mêmes milieux
en revanche j'aurais juste un
commentaire à produire caution
délégation européenne je trouve qu'ils
jouent avec le feu là encore hier je
l'écouté avec attention quand il dit sur
l'europe l'europe ne fait rien quand
elle est qu'il n'y a qu'en tatoueur
pardon ni éloigné je crois que là
effectivement il est très à côté du
sujet et qu' il faut faire attention aux
mots et il faut dire les choses quoi
l'europe marche pas et son rôle c'est à
dire que l'europe marche pas et qu'il va
falloir se plonger dedans pour la
réparer mais pas nous faire croire
qu'elle fait à peu près ce qu'il faut
fra un autre thème sur l'europe une
autre fois mais là je crois qu'on va ça
notre deuxième sujet non vous c'est vrai
que c'est important volet ça a été très
solide et effectivement c'est dans leur
sélection
c'est vraiment on va dresser le match
dans les conditions du match les
nationalistes il ya les gentils et des
méchants déjà ce qui est un peu facile
là aussi ça laisse de l'espace on aborde
le deuxième sujet c'est celui de ce
rapport sénatorial et une proposition à
ces chocs en dix ans le salafisme et
bien il faut qu'il soit inscrit au
nombre des dérives sectaires
c'est donc une proposition d'un rapport
piloté par deux sénateurs l'un la
république en marche l'autre union
centriste
on s'en souvient à emmanuel manuel valls
parle l'ex premier ministre avait voulu
aussi interdire le salafisme alors
est-ce une proposition efficaces
réalistes
en attendant l'acta est accusée de ne
rien faire par une partie de
l'opposition pour endiguer cette menace
terroriste c'est l'avis de guillaume
larrivé secrétaire général délégué des
républicains et député de l'yonne il
était ce matin sur l'a
le parlementaire je constate que sur
cette question majeure de la lutte
contre l'islamisme qui est un projet
politique de subversion de notre pays je
constate pardon que depuis 13 mois
maintenant
la majorité s'est tourné les pouces si
vous permettez cette expression
familière donc il est vraiment grand
temps d'agir
ce qu'on peut pas accepter qu'ils aient
une partie du territoire national une
partie de la communauté nationale qui en
réalité faire sécession et qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui soumise à la charia donc à
la catho la majorité se tourner les
pouces sur la question du terrorisme
c'est pas le sujet préféré de la
majorité actuelle il faut bien dire
c'est un sujet où on voit se recomposer
les clivages que macron nous avait
promis disparaître sur des sujets comme
ça y compris au sein du groupe la
république en marche et du parti on voit
bien la gauche renette la droite
renaître et derrière des problématiques
et aussi beaucoup de d'ambiguïté c'est
un vrai sujet et le sujet est compliqué
avec le rapport sénatorial il a il
al'avantage d'explorer une piste qui
effectivement la dérive sectaire
après on sait qu'il ya plusieurs types
de salafisme salafisme s'est pas
uniquement un salafisme jihadiste qui
tend à des opérations terroristes c'est
d'abord majoritairement dans ce pays je
dirais une une bataille idéologique pour
reprendre en main une communauté
musulmane que les salafis juge perverti
par l'occident et par la modernité et la
ramener dans une approche beaucoup plus
littéral beaucoup plus traditionalistes
de la pratique de l'islam donc que les
salafistes pour la majorité en france
n'ont aucun intérêt à voir se multiplier
les opérations terroristes
ils sont très contents de pouvoir
continuer à travailler dans les écoles
dans les domaines associatif dans le
domaine humanitaire
sans faire de bruit en progressant par
rapport à leur bataille idéologique
donc effectivement comment les
appréhender sans remettre en cause des
valeurs importantes dans notre société
que sont la liberté d'association la
liberté d'expression la liberté
d'opinion d'inscrire sa non moi je
trouve que c'est malin de prendre ça
sous l'aspect c'est clair avec une vraie
difficulté juridique c'est que dès que
vous commencez à appliquer le mot secte
un fait religieux
vous ouvrez effectivement la boîte de
pandore et et vous créer des réactions
très épidermique dans les milieux
religieux je dirais institutionnels
traditionnels
que ce soit les catholiques les
protestants ou où la communauté juive et
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un défi à
relever qui est un défi juridique en
france c'est-à-dire à où est ce qu'on
met le curseur
comment est-ce qu'on peut interdire par
exemple à des parents de faire porter
des vêtements religieux à leurs enfants
au plus bas âge des vêtements religieux
qui les discriminent socialement je vois
qu'on voit bien que c'est le cas d'un
certain nombre de jeunes femmes et de
très jeunes filles de plus en plus dans
certains dans certains quartiers en
france mais la réponse qui doit être
juridique parce qu'on est dans un état
de droit les difficiles à trouver et et
moi je pense que c'est intéressant qu'on
ici une proposition qui viennent à la
fois
enfin qui viennent de deux familles
politiques différentes aux seynois du
moulin sur cette question précise de
possibilité d'inscrire sa oui mes fesses
c'est bien mais ça n'ira pas sûrement
pas assez loin pourquoi parce que le
qualificatif de secte on sait très bien
que la jurisprudence le l'évaluent de
manière très très très méticuleuse et il
faut tout un ensemble de critères et
donc on est parti pour des batailles
juridiques pour dire oui c'était
l'association est une secte
et puis qu'est ce qu'ils ont qualifié
l'emprise aussi bien sûr et qu'est ce
qui empêche toute façon une association
salafistes 10 août dont la mosquée a été
fermée de se reconstituer sous un autre
nom durera non nous on est passé à les
fils mangèrent telle école on gère une
une salle de sport dont on se rend
compte finalement que c'est une salle de
prière ça arrive très fréquemment
en fait on passe vraiment en train de
mailles du filet faut dire on n'est pas
forcément aidés par des par une
tradition très libéral de la justice qui
pouvait avoir cessé sa cohérence l'ours
qui avant la menace salafiste mais là on
parle de la menace salafiste mais il ya
aussi
et alors les chiffres c'est exactement
il ya 120 mosquées salafistes et
quelques-unes 11 je crois ont été fermés
mais elles ont réouvert parce que
notamment ils ont gagné ce regorgent
hills mais il ya aussi 147 mosquée
tabligh et 200 masques et de l'unef
donc vous mettez ça bout à bout les
sources que je donne ces services
centrale du renseignement intérieur hier
on se rend compte que oui moi je suis
d'accord avec ce rapport sénatorial ou
sssa sénatoriales
le gouvernement n'est pas la hauteur il
ya tout ce qu'il faut en matière de
renseignement et après les décisions
elles elles arrivent au compte gouttes
samcon et puis on les découvre qu'au
bout d'un attentat que en fait le
terroriste était fichiers c'est qu'on
n'a rien fait parce qu'on peut pas
suivre tout le monde alors gouvernement
pas à la hauteur ou finalement absence
de nécessité de faire un plan un énième
plan et applications de ce qui existe et
de la législation
ils sont pas à la hauteur depuis
longtemps le premier rapport alarmiste
et daté de 2004 il a été enterré et on a
continué à enterrer et c'est vrai que si
des je n'avais pas fait un des pas
survenu on aurait continué à laisser
s'enkyster s'enraciner toute une série
de pratiques et dérives que moi je crois
qu'ils sont intolérables
au regard de nos valeurs et de nos
standards et puis en plus qui sont pas
dans une voie d'extinction sont plutôt
en voie de prosélytisme développement
donc ça ça ça a des racines qui sont
très profondes parce qu'on aurait dû dès
le départ appartement mon a commencé à
accepter une immigration nouvelle avec
une religion nouvelle il fallait poser
le problème dès les années 60 se peut
dire qu'est ce qu'on va faire ensemble
et comment est-ce qu'on va gérer cette
question là on a fait du mousseau le
voilà tout va bien veut régler en
marchant et vers sanaa gérer la question
maintenant le mal il est extrêmement
profond dire que vous avez vraiment
effectivement dans des quartiers dans
des zones et dans une partie des
populations alors elle est peut-être
marginal mais il n'empêche qu'elle pose
un véritable problème il suffit de voir
sur internet
comment des conseils crime sur ces
questions là quelle violence ça peut
mener ses expériences la semaine
dernière quelle violence ça génère quand
on dit quelque chose
quand on monte prononce le mot charia en
disant qu'effectivement il ya des
pratiques à des dérives
il ya des comportements inacceptables ça
réagit extrêmement violemment alors ils
sont peut-être pas très nombreux mais en
ont il n'empêche que c'est un vrai
symptômes alors l'idée de deux qualifiés
du point de vue juridique nation on est
dans un état de droit donc la seule
réponse et juridique ne peut pas être
policier au sens humaniste rativeau
d'idron table de dangeau eure état de
droit il faut effectivement un cadre
sauf que là ça va être effective en
prison mais ça suffira pas évidemment
derrière vous avez l'école évidemment
que vous avez une lutte internationale
sur les grilles différentes et 1% dans
ce rapport un chiffre parmi d'autres
41 % d'augmentation de la
déscolarisation c'est-à-dire d'enfants
qui sont retirés de l'école avec leurs
camarades pour être scolarisés à la
maison
+41 % en deux ans je crois ne mettez pas
forcément que pour des questions
religieuses ou pour des questions liées
au salafisme le problème
de la population qui étudiait la vidéo
et le problème c'est que autant
l'inscription comme groupements
sectaires peut-être utile c'est
effectivement comme vous disiez ça
n'empêchera pas forcément les gens de
demi un salafiste ou les associations de
surmonter à côté ce rapport qui pointe
pour moi il a deux avantages
1 il pointe les grosses carences et
insuffisances du dispositif actuel en
montrant que l'êta est complètement
dépassé par la situation n'est pas
capable de la prévenir et complètement
dépassé et de il fait des propositions
qui sont très pratico pratique autre que
d'inscrire juridiquement dans laquelle
il revient d'ailleurs sur ce qu'elle ait
fait quand même jusqu'à perdu françois
hollande en 2016 c'est à dire est-ce
qu'il faut inscrire ou pas dans la
constitution la déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux
ce rapport trans partisan dit oui ce
qu'ils avaient quand même conduit la
gauche à sa perte en 2016 et surtout il
dit qu'il faut mieux gérer les sorties
de prison des gens qui ont été
radicalisé parce que là on est l'agent
la nature on ne sait pas quoi en faire
ils ont beau être fichier est ce même
après leur sortie toute façon le droit
aujourd'hui ne parlait pas d'hier était
mieux informer les maires des fichiers
est ce qu'ils sont alors comme il en
parle des carences de l'état
effectivement il n'y a pas qu'une
carence juridique à une carence
administrative on parlera la des
vermines fonctionnaires qu'on veut mais
la déscolarisation ça se contrôle
l'état doit contrôler et contrôler y
compris jusque dans les familles comment
sont scolarisés par leurs parents ont
éduqué par leurs parents les enfants est
ce que l'état les moyens de le faire
aujourd'hui y compris pour cette
population on parle des fonctionnaires
de bercy mais le problème est un indé un
des axes l'un des leviers pour agir
contre ces associations c'est le
contrôle des finances le contrôle de
l'origine des fonds de contrôle de il
vous mettriez des inspecteurs des impôts
plutôt que des policiers pour aller
contrôler ces associations cultuelles
culturel ou je ne sais quoi on
trouverait des moyens d'agir qu'on a
déjà utilisé par le passé dans d'autres
sujets et sur d'autres sur d'autres
schémas
donc il ya effectivement des leviers qui
sont dans le temps dans ce rapport mais
qui sont non seulement ce truc mais sous
dotées en moyens cd avec quoi avoir de
problème à gré cité le pouvoir politique
notamment certaines mairies 9e
neuf pas avoir les banlieues qui
s'enflamme donc on achète la paix
sociale et ont dit aux policiers non non
vous contrôlez juste l'entrée et la
sortie mais vous n'allez pas l'intérieur
récent d'une certaine façon ce que
finalement l'état c'est nous les tasses
et de la représentation elle est
fabriquée par la représentation
politique qui effectivement derrière va
fabriquer un état donc on est le reflet
de ça on a voulu ça il faut avoir
conscience que qu'est ce qu'on est prêt
aujourd'hui acceptée pour rétablir
l'état de droit
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter qu'il
faut trois mois à notre dame des landes
pour arriver avec 2000 crs gendarmes et
policiers
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter qu'on
casse pendant cinq jours un quartier
entier un homme parce qu'il ya eu
peut-être une bavure on verra la suite
de l'histoire et on l'espère pendant
cinq nuits et ainsi de suite et ça fait
30 ans que ça dure à chaque fois qu'il
ya un problème tout le monde qu'elle
soit enfin si moi je suis de demain
victimes de n'importe quoi je vais pas
les casser tout autour de moi on tolère
ça donc on a on a accepté cette espèce
de d'établissement d'un état parce que
l'acceptabilité général de la population
si demain on utilise vraiment les moyens
des moyens sérieux pour rétablir l'état
de droit là où c'est nécessaire
est ce qu'on est prêt à accepter voilà
moi je pose la question vous avez
peut-être suivi cette affaire de l'imam
de toulouse qui a selon certains dans un
prêche fait un appel au meurtre des
juifs
céline pina qui est une ancienne élue
locale qui fait une tribune aujourd'hui
dans le figaro vox pour dire que tout ça
est assez scandaleux à ses yeux
cet imam ça fait une vingtaine d'années
je crois qu'il qu'il officie est le fait
des prêches uniquement en arabe selon
les renseignements qu'on a
certains disent que régulièrement il ya
des dérives dans ses prêches
ça fait partie de ces illustrations on a
du mal finalement à trouver le la bonne
mesure on peut se demander si
effectivement le il faudrait pas mieux
avoir des tout de suite un une réponse
assez ferme
c'est indispensable enfin giresse qu'on
peut accepter que dans un état comme la
france on ne puisse pas rentrer dans un
incident un lieu de religion parce qu'on
n'est pas la même religion fin vers
n'importe qui peut rentrer dans une
église aujourd'hui
allez un vendredi dans une région de
mosquées en tant que non non fidèles
vous rentrez pas donc j'ai rien que ce
type de pratique la tolérance de ce type
de protection du territoire et
complètement contraire aux principes
effectivement de valeur que nous devons
partager un moment donné ça doit être
des lieux ouverts et quand on pratique
se fait-il alors 6 et 6 s'est qualifié
derrière et évidemment si c'est vrai il
faut engager des pour des poursuites on
peut pas se contenter de space de
laisser faire une fois plus parce que
c'est vrai quand on dit les tailles non
létales et tabarez ne répond pas et
qu'est ce qui va se passer l'an prochain
les français vont voter comme comme il
le mérite c'est à dire et ce thème
environnement de mots sur les images
pour deux pour parler vrai puisque
l'expulsion des imams radicaux ça fait
des années qu'on en parle et plusieurs
gouvernements s'y sont cassé le nez sur
cette question bat juridiquement mais
aussi diplomatiques montebourg est très
clair pour expulser un imam il faut bien
tout lui trouvé que le pays vers lequel
voulait depuis ces sois d'accord pour
l'accueillir
or on va dire les choses très clairement
il ya des pays du maghreb notamment
l'algérie qui refuse de récupérer les
imams radicaux qui préfère les voir en
france plus du chant français peuvent
peut être que pire il ya la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui une
fois qu'on a réussi à les condamner à
condamner et à les expulser hors
d'algérie dit adan à nous regarder
ils vont avoir des traitements inhumains
et des tortures en algérie donc c'est
pas faux et et donc nous avait rejeté
conserver au frais du comté de contra de
la réalité et on les loge à l'hôtel des
arguments c'est bien aussi on préfère
qu'ils soient like on surveille un petit
peu ce qui se passe autour de sanaa ici
un service qui effectivement préfère les
avoir les imams à disposition et qui
même organisé une sorte de rotation des
imams ce qui on en a pas parlé mais il
ya une très très forte violence et
concurrence entre les différents
courants de pensée au sein de l'islam de
france et vous avez notamment à
marseille
un cas très intéressant pas tous mais à
marseille où un imam salafiste vient
d'être remplacée avec la bénédiction des
autorités françaises par un imam issu
des frères musulmans je ne sais pas ce
qu'on a gagné je ne sais pas trop ce
qu'on a perdu mais on voit bien qu'il ya
un jeu parfois un peu trouble y compris
des autorités françaises sur la gestion
une vraie gestion politique et publique
de l'islam en france
quelques réactions toujours sur ce sujet
pascal parce qu'elle est une femme
l'état de droit doivent faire respecter
la loi tout simplement claude on a
besoin d'un peu d'autorité face au
laxisme des trente dernières années
léonard da l'état se cache derrière la
justice mais c'est notre justice qui
n'est pas adapté je vous livre une
histoire personnelle vous parler
d'éducation et de civisme et de ça il se
trouve que j'ai eue lors du
histoire dans une école du 15e
arrondissement à paris les parents
d'élèves des autres élèves voyez arriver
deux jeunes garçons accompagnés de leurs
soeurs voilée lesquels soeur accompagner
leurs enfants enfin leurs frères
jusqu'aux portes de l'école et ensuite
on rentre et on a demandé quelques
parents demander qu'est-ce que pourquoi
vous n'allez pas l'école et les petites
filles ont répondu ah ben non moi c'est
l'école à la maison et les les autorités
de l'école enfin la direction de l'école
de laverty adia où on sait mais on peut
rien faire dans l'immédiat c'est faux
parce qu'ils ont non seulement ils
doivent faire enfin ils peuvent faire
ils doivent faire c'est une obligation
légale de contrôler la manière dont sont
éduqués des enfants qui sont
déscolarisés et que l'on est dans un
état de droit la scolarité la
scolarisation la maison s'il est
autorisé à partir du moment où elle est
fait dans les règles il faut il faut
contrôler et vous le verrez une et à
l'obligation contrôler que ces règles
sont appliquées ça veut dire que dans le
cas que vous citiez il ya peut-être une
école coranique
c'est beau mais c'est pas impossible on
découvre quelques fois qu'il ya un petit
temps une petite salle qui sert d'école
et encore une fois chacun alors il ya
une un principe de liberté
d'enseignement mais à condition de le
faire dans les règles
il n'empêche qu'une partie de la droite
a critiqué les conditions qui ont été
émises pour mieux contrôler les écoles
hors contrat en disant c'est une
atteinte à deux bien sûr j'ai bien sûr
mais parce que là on parle de choses
différentes faut savoir que dans les
écoles hors contrat vous avez à peu près
2% d'écoles musulmanes tout le reste
soit il ya beaucoup d'écoles montessori
des écoles non confessionnelle de il
doit avoir 15% de mémoire ou peut-être
un peu plus écoles catholiques d'écoles
juives mais les les les musulmans
n'utilise pas forcément ce levier c'est
beaucoup le levier périscolaire les
associations ou à soi disco sauvage soit
des salles de sport des associations
culturelles dont on ne sait pas trop ce
qu'elles font voilà c'est plutôt là
dessus qu'il faudrait la gimone nouvelle
retenir quand même parce que les gens
qui nous regardent peuvent s'inquiéter
légitimement mais malgré tout il ya une
vraie prise de conscience à la fois
parce qu'on dit l'état l'état l'état
c'est vrai que l'état a pris du retard
l'état s'est laissé déborder mais
aujourd'hui on n'est plus dans la même
situation à celle qu'on a on a
conscience qu'il ya une vraie menace qui
est un vrai péril on sait pas trop
comment de l'attraper quand on est aussi
en fonction politique parce que c'est
très explosive comme sujet mais il ya
une action de fond qui est menée alors
ce sera malheureusement ce sera long
parce qu'on a on a pris trop de retard
notre troisième sujet c'est celui des
finances publiques c'est le gros
chantier qui s'ouvre pour le
gouvernement avec we des façons de
savoir comment on va faire des économies
où quand comment
des informations commencent à fuiter sur
la façon de s'y prendre l'une des pistes
c'est bercy avec cette idée peut-être un
peu machiavélique que commencer par
tailler dans les effectifs de ceux qui
collectent l'info serait une mesure
populaire le chiffre de vingt mille
suppressions de poste à bercy a été
évoqué ces quelques derniers jours
chiffre démenti officiellement mais
démenti un peu mollement par benjamin
griveaux porte parole du gouvernement
qui était ce matin sur france info
évident que avec la numérisation avec
par exemple la suppression à terme des
taxes d'habitation avec le prélèvement à
la source de l'impôt sur le revenu il
est difficile de dire qu'on va maintenir
l'ensemble des missions avec le nombre
de personnes en face des missions pour
des missions qui disparaissent marc
landré c'est effectivement une des
pistes des principales pistes
d'économies
une des principales pistes d'économie il
faut savoir de quoi on parle là
l'hypothèse ses vingt mille personnes
la promesse d' emmanuel macron ans aux
banques un cada ses 120 mille
suppressions de postes de fonctionnaires
dont 50 milles dans la sphère de l'état
donc ça veut dire que là on parle de
20000 postes sur cinquante mille puisque
les soixante dix mille autres ses
fonctions publiques territoriale donc ça
veut dire que sur un seul ministère
20000 c'est 40 % 40 % sur un ministère
qui n'en fait plus que 130 aujourd'hui
parce que il a déjà fondu de 20 % de ses
effectifs depuis le début des années
2000 et que l'année dernière cette année
pardon dans le budget 2010 8 il a déjà
perdu 1500 personnes donc oui
effectivement de tout temps lorsqu'il ya
eu des réductions d'effectifs dans la
sphère publique de l'état
bercy a toujours été aux armes en garde
parce que un c'est lui qui prend les
décisions dont qui montre l'exemple et
deux parce que c'est là il ya du grain à
moudre
cela dit cela dit dans les benjamin
griveaux qui n'a pas son penchant pour
dire des conneries a dit à die ou
e-bonds aux normales avec le prélèvement
à la source assez logique que la version
c'est vrai sauf qu'il va falloir dans un
premier temps limiter les bugs
les agents on va en avoir besoin pour
aller contrôler que le justement le dit
prélèvement à la source fonctionne bien
et je ne suis pas certain qu'en deux ans
on soit capable de supprimer un nombre
de postes surtout que ça se fera sans
licenciement aussi la sphère des
licenciements ce sera dans le cadre d'un
plan de départs volontaires qui va
falloir négocier et c'est bon mais on
n'y est pas en tout cas des agents au
fisc aujourd'hui on veut en avoir besoin
parce que le prélèvement à la source ça
va être un sacré bordel à mettre en
oeuvre et qu'on va avoir besoin d'argent
d'agents pour corriger la ou les bugs
vont avoir lieu donc je suis pas certain
qu'on puisse dès maintenant dire qu'on
va pouvoir supprimer des postes
ici dans cinq ans c'est une autre
histoire on est content débat on écoute
aussi alors sur un sujet toujours le
même sujet mais un peu plus large
laurent wauquiez laurent wauquiez qui
était donc ce matin l'invité de rmc
il fait une leçon d'économie émana
makoun ce qui me gêne c'est que ce
président de la république a fait la
suppression des ss oui mais qu'il n'a
rien fait de l'autre côté il n'y a eu
aucune baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu
que on à augmenter la csg sur les
retraités pourquoi ça se passe comme ça
parce qu'il ne fait pas d'économies sur
la dépense publique
et comme il fait pas d'économies sur la
dépense publique va l'argent qu'il a
donnée sur l' isf
il est obligé de le prendre dans la
poche des classes moyennes le sens
convaincant tout un peu que c'est le
sait un peu démagogique dire qu'on
attend enfin quand on voit ce qu'a fait
la droite pendant entre 2007 et 2012 je
crois qu'elle a pas trop d'exemples à
donner alors après ce qui est vrai c'est
que il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui l'on attend la
baisse de la dépense publique je crois
que c'est pas en allant rogner moi je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
marc landry s'est pas vingt mille
suppressions de postes a bercy c'est
vraiment beaucoup et on va voir plein de
contentieux en cascade avec l'impôt à la
source donc c'est pas vraiment en
rognant sur les ministères pc en
redéfinissant le périmètre de l'état et
de ce qui est ou pas pris en charge
notamment puisqu'on parle d'éducation
tout à l'heure moi je crois vraiment que
puisque c'est le premier poste
budgétaire de l'état on pourrait mettre
en place comme l'a fait la suède ce
système du chèque scolaire vous savez où
vous donner finalement un chèque aux
parents qui vont se scolariser leurs
enfants dans l'école de leur choix bien
sûr il faut que cette école suivi d'un
cahier des charges et dans ce cas là
nous permettait qu'elle soit dans le
public privé et là par exemple vous
diminuer une masse salariale tout en
gardant le cahier des charges de l'école
républicaine alors ça ça serait une
bonne mesure mais bon c'est vrai que là
maintenant l'impression qu'on va je sais
très bien c'est le programme
programme aujourd'hui mais là on a
l'impression que c'est vraiment des
goûts des boudé des fonds de tiroirs il
va chercher surtout que dans les selles
que dans les missions régaliennes
on a besoin au contraire et il a été
fait un peu mais ça devrait être fait
beaucoup plus les missions de la police
de la justice
le budget de l'ue 6 et est vraiment
souffre d'une grande carence et de la
défense on a besoin de les renforcer
pourquoi avoir attendu un an cap 2022
pourquoi avoir attendu un an pour le
faire et maintenant dire que finalement
on va pas dire qu'il ya dans le rapport
je rappelle qu'à 2022 pour résumé marc
hein c'est bien ça c'est toutes les
économies justement à faire en matière
de dépenses publiques qu'à deux c'est
c'est un comité ad-hoc qui a été
constituée de gens qui ont fait des
économies dans des pays étrangers et
d'experts qui étaient chargés
d'aiguillonner le gouvernement sur là où
il faut tailler dans les dépenses
publiques en france
ce rapport devait être rendu public au
mois de mars qui ne l'a pas été il ne le
sera jamais puisque trop sensible cela
dit je pense que le gouvernement a
raison parce que certains combien
rapport sur la table on va regarder ce
qu'il ya dedans est ce que du
gouvernement décide de ne pas reprendre
prenez le rapport spinetta sur la sncf
on a focalisé sur la fermeture des
petites des mines non rentables ce que
le gouvernement dès le départ a dit je
ne leur prend pas à mon compte
la réforme ferroviaire ne concernera pas
les lignes non rentables
pourtant encore aujourd'hui l'opposition
lui parle de le démineur entame donc en
vérité ces questions des chiffons rouges
de dire je vais pas je vais pas mettre
un bâton supplémentaire pour le battre
ça va déjà être suffisamment compliqué
je vais d être suffisamment critiqué sur
les choix que je vais devoir prendre si
en plus je vais me faire engueuler pour
des décisions que je prends pas donc
qu'on pense que je vais prendre je vais
pas m'en sortir
donc c'est plus une question de méthode
une question d'effectivité il n'en reste
pas moins vrai qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron a prévu une baisse de 4
points de pib de dépenses publiques sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat ce qui revient
à faire que la dépense publique
augmentera de 100 milliards de moins que
ce qu'elle aurait augmenté naturellement
si on ne freinait pas la hausse des
dépenses et c'est 100 milliards et bien
fort il trouvait quelque part et pour
l'instant on ne va pas le début d'une
queue de cerise économie emmanuel macron
et le pire élève de la classe européenne
en matière de déficits publics
dakhla la gestion de l'argent public et
du bilan du budget de l'état par le ce
quinquennat et
très inquiétante et inquiète énormément
nos partenaires européens moyenne de 0
5% l'union européenne 2 4 2 3% c'est
moins que les 3 % c'est vrai on en dire
mais on se glorifie d'être en dessous
des 3% quand tous nos partenaires sont
en dessous de 1% voire voire en excédent
c'est ça la réalité dans laquelle nous
sommes donc la politique budgétaire et
du budget public mené par le quinquennat
est très inquiétant beaucoup de cadeaux
fiscaux très très peu d'économie et très
peu d'économies structurelles
la deuxième chose c'est on reprend on
les taille d'une entreprise donc on va
faire comme comme dans une assemblée
générale ont annoncé à ses actionnaires
qu on fait des confédérés licenciement
par paquet et on espère que la cote de
l'action va remonter sur les marchés
financiers
la réalité c'est que on ne nous dit rien
de ce que nous avons besoin pour demain
en termes de fonctions publiques
moi je suis d'accord on peut redéfinir
le périmètre de l'état pourquoi pas
lançons le sujet mais de quel
fonctionnaire on a besoin - la question
sais pas si on a besoin de plus ou de
moi c'est quel fonctionnaire on veut on
parle de bercy on ne vient de le dire il
ya des vrais problèmes aujourd'hui et
des vrais besoins sur la lutte contre le
blanchiment sur la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale sur le financement des
activités criminelles au niveau mondial
on cherche désespérément des datas
scientist des nouveaux profils des gens
qui soient capables d'enquêter pour le
bien commun et à bercy s'est pas
uniquement des gens qui vont faire du
prélèvement à la source donc la question
c'est pas combien on en a versé 4 sont
les nouvelles fonctions qu'on attribue à
l'état et comment est-ce qu'on modernise
l'état là dessus on nous dit absolument
rien et les fonctionnaires sont pas une
variable d'ajustement c'est un service
public derrière un dernier mot à
alexandrie pour dire que voilà c'est une
confusion eu une fois de plus d'être de
la fin des moyens dire qu on oublie
comme pour la réforme de la sncf on
oublie projet d'entreprise alors qu'il
ya un vrai projet d'entreprise à
défendre et là il ya un vrai projet pour
l'état
quel état demain quelle mission est ce
qu'à un moment donné il faut pas revenir
en arrière des différentes fonctions
publiques pour justement essayer
d'harmoniser la gestion des ressources
humaines
il faut repartir démission il faut
appartenant à se réaliser il faut
peut-être travailler avec les équipes
telles que le but de réduire de 20 mille
fonctionnaires c'est peut-être bien
entamée économies mais peut-être qu'il
ya des solutions en interne il faut
peut-être s'appuyer sur les compétences
dans les services pour de bon on a un
nombre de missions à revoir il faut les
rendre plus efficaces avait peut-être
moins de moyens mieux de moyens et puis
de faire travailler sous sa au service
d'une meilleure d'une plus grande
efficience seront faits dans les
entreprises on est capable dans une
autre boss de faire bosser les gens sur
le terrain par direction par service
pour arriver avant elle
est ce qu'au progrès et pas
effectivement par le haut que d'y aller
tout d'un coup moins d'un mille parce
que c'est vraiment ça crée du stress de
l'incertitude ne comprend pas la vision
alors on comprend à l'économie peut-être
à contourner libéral mais si on n'est
pas libre en dise pourquoi encore juste
un dernier point ces derniers parce que
vous vous ruiner tout sépare les deux
restent non mais c'est une info que le
figaro a sorti la semaine dernière et
qui a été confirmé par le gouvernement
et qui je trouve est classé alarmiste et
dangereuse initialement au mois d'avril
lorsqu'on a envoyé notre programme de
stabilité à bruxelles on avait prévu de
ramener de finir le quinquennat dedans
dans le vert c'est à dire avec un
excédent de 0 3 point de pib
bah finalement on s'est rendu compte que
la dent les deux nouveaux documents qui
ont été envoyés par le gouvernement aux
parlementaires
on finira à léquilibre servir qu'en
trois mois on a perdu 0,3 point pi
pourquoi parce qu'on a décidé de
financer le cadeau électoral de la
suppression de l' intégralité la taxe
d'habitation par des déficits pas par
des économies supplémentaires
et ça c'est très inquiétant parce que le
président qui se gargarise d'avoir
inventé un nouveau monde reprend les
mêmes méthodes de l'ancien monde que
d'un financier ces cadeaux par du
déficit et ça c'est très alarmant
pensez vous qu'il est nécessaire de
réduire le nombre de fonctionnaires à
bercy vous vous en doutez peut-être un
peu et pour les internautes du figaro
c'est 75% qui répondent oui trois sur
quatre
claude on ne va pas garder les
fonctionnaires de bercy alors qu on
numérise de tous les côtés daniel les
économies doivent commencer par les
politiques supprimant 70% des députés et
100% des sénateurs à ce compte là il y
aura plus grand monde pour répondre à
emmanuel macron alors le foot le foot
alors pas un homme ou une femme
politique en ce moment à qui on ne
demande pas de prévoir le score du match
de ce soir
il s'y prête d'ailleurs de bonne grâce
sans doute de peur de paraître
déconnecté des français c'est la même
chose dans la rue plein micro trottoir
comme on les appelle ils donnent
d'ailleurs tous que même résultat la
france en finale tandis que les belges
eux jurent que les diables rouges vont
gagner bref les tout ça explose les
paris en ligne aussi on mise sur tout le
résultat mais aussi le nom des buteurs
le score à la mi-temps où l'éventualité
des tirs au but
alors vous allez si vous le voulez nous
donner votre pronostic
mais vous analysez aussi le phénomène
foot
parler foot c'est faire peuple alexandra
la faille est bonne et je crois que il
ya un petit défaut souvent il ya une
espèce de dérive un peu nationaliste qui
ce qui s'organise et des pays qui sont
privés de foot se sont lâchés prenez le
cas de l'italie qui est privé de coupe
du monde la politique a pris un tour
assez assez inquiétant qu est ce qui se
serait passé en italie avait pas eu de
coupe du monde veut c'est qu'ils avaient
participé peut-être qu'il en serait il
en serait pas là enfin bon ça c'est un
petit petit petit travail dont les choix
que tout le monde a faim on est dans un
monde d'information continue donc il
faut il faut voilà il faut être avec il
faut montrer qu'on s'intéresse il faut
montrer de l'empathie
ça fait partie de cette époque moderne
un peu un peu curieuse où tout le monde
en fait parfois un peu beaucoup un peu
trop jolie y compris sur la mise en
scène face ce soir notre président on
prend un avion aux mêmes cinq personnes
va assister au match très bien a bon on
a vu le couac de la semaine dernière
avec l'effectif approché aussi un nom
mais je crois qu'à un moment donné il
faut de la tranquillité
je fais si la france est en finale et
qui va pas la finale à la je pense qu il
faut la simplicité tous cas on veut pas
être partout on peut pas être au congrès
on peut pas être en permanence en train
de tourner autour du monde
et puis il faut se concentrer sur les
dossiers enfin pardon mais même si on
est très très intelligente et plus
intelligent que la moyenne
il faut quand même gérer un truc
compliqué qui s'appelle un gouvernement
un état un pays dans un monde complexe
l'on peut pas être partout tout le temps
comme ça ne veut pas se faire de piscine
alors que bien aller voir un match de
foot ça réconcilie tout le monde au pas
le foot bénac - bah c'est je suis mitigé
dire que c'est à la fois beau de voir
une cité vibrer et là pour le coup on
voit des drapeaux français on aspes de
regard de patriotisme dans le marc
landré douceur sans plus mais voilà
c'est pas ta fait le drapeau français ce
qu'ils feraient que ce soit de ce côté
là on a l'impression que ces soldes
luxembourg la france mais
mais alors ça c'est le bon côté mais en
même temps quelque fois on se dit mais
et on regrette que c'est que pour le
foot qui lui firent est un spectacle
quand même qu'on est capable de vivre et
sa montre l'être humain en fait il a
besoin de vivre des sortes d'émotions
collectives mais faudrait pas que ce
soit réduit uniquement à saint andré oui
aussi des exutoires faudrait que ça soit
vraiment ancrée dans des dents dans
quelque chose
un vivre ensemble mais pas pas comme on
nous le sert tout le temps à l'envers de
journée quelque chose qui soit vraiment
ancré sur ce que qui nous relie entre
nous et j'espère qu'il ya autre chose
que le foot
oui alors deux choses d'abord moi je je
sais gré à emmanuel macron passe moi je
ne suis pas du tout le foot ainsi tous
les quatre ans je redécouvre des
non-juifs outils mais je vais suivre le
match mais je m'intéresse au foot tous
les quatre ans elhorga juste récompense
que finalement gg page et je retourne à
mes 20 ans guy roux jean pierre papin au
jeu j'ai mes références
donc merci manuel da cruz
la deuxième chose c'est que fais tu
manges suis d'accord ça crée une
émulation et c'est pour ça que j'en veux
énormément à notre équipe nationale
d'avoir battu l'argentine parce que je
pense que un pays comme l'argentine
avait bien plus besoin de l'exultation
et de l'espérance que crée ce genre
d'événement plutôt que la france qui va
grâce à notre cher président extrêmement
bien marc landré vous avez la question
c'est est ce que finalement c'est pas à
travers aussi à ces français ont
commencé il ya plus qu'a commencé le
mondial on commence pour dénigrer le
sélectionneur n'est plus et pire aux
mesures de trois semaines qu'on en a
fini premier de la poule et moi je suis
nul en floutant gym franchement les
joueurs de l'équipe de france mise à
part lloris je ne sais pas qui c'est et
un mec qui s'appelle griezmann qui a une
coupe de cheveux à peu près exactement
ont vaguement mois suivants je suis
federer
non mais à combien il a été chronométré
au km 37 ya trois semaines l'équipe de
france était nulle on est en train
dénigrer que deschamps parce que il
caché son jeu et qui la dépouillent
n'allait pas gagner et c'est que
vraiment tout ça pour ça on dépenser
dépenser trop dépenser trop d'argent et
on se tape soit l'argentine ça c'est
encore huitièmes de finale
on leur met quatre ou trois buts d'écart
3 voilà et ça devient ça y est il faut
il va être président de la république
fin juin on est on est dans ce côté
extrémiste france 2 l'ex et français
voilà on aime détester ce qu'on a adoré
on derna d'or ce qu'on aime détester
je pense que si si ce soit la france
gagne bas eh ben on va revoir le retour
de la france black blanc beur une france
métissée où tout le monde s'aime
s'embrasse sur la bouche est celle que
trop parce que dans mes à 80,18 ont été
oui mais est-ce qu'on va les renvoyer
revenir alors la question qu'on vous
pose et ben vous êtes 73% à dire que la
france va gagner ce soir
en tout cas vous pouvez rester sur
figaro live parce que le foot c'est pour
dans presque tout de suite à 18h30 dès
18h30 vous retrouvez les envoyés
spéciaux du figaro en russie nos
journalistes sportifs martin couturier
laurent louette et quelques et des
invités et il ya maintenant
non je voulais pas venir dans le jeu
donc je vais vous en tout cas il ya
yannick agnel le nageur nageurs double
médaillé olympique à londres je crois
qui sera sur le plateau c'est l'avant
match la mi-temps l'après-match tout ça
sur figaro life merci beaucoup à tous
les cas merci mais la santé nous avoir
si c'est poutine qui gueule non à la fin
de toute façon chaque fois qu'on a
compris poutine aura récolter les
bénéfices de cette coupe du monde
merci beaucoup à tous et vous retrouver
guillaume roquette demain pour point de
vue
[Musique]